oh
[Musique]
un nom
non
oh
2 mais
il
il faut et
j oh
[Musique]
c'est vrai que pendant votre voyage de
noces charles porter les cadeaux de
camilla
j'ai parfaitement conscience
de la fonctions que j'exerce
en particulier ce soir le vécu comme les
passagers d'un avion avait plusieurs
classes qui boit du champagne
sachant que l'avion va s'écraser sur la
montagne
[Musique]
et l'on se sent tout seul peut-être le
même nom
que j'ai renvoyé attendez j'ai envoyé
environ
deux ou trois mois je peux vous le dire
en consultant le registre un jour j'en
ai chopé âme lui dit dont des ouvriers
de chez renault ou venez pas les faire
chier de dimanche c'est pas moi c'est
pareil quand je me repose chez moi vaut
prévenir m'emmerder moi la femme libre à
qui personne n'a dictait sa loi un même
panier que là c'était au petit soin pour
toi
c'est ça c'est un peu d'âme et de la
médecine chinoise ouais et on voit un
petit peu tout ce qui va pas longtemps
encore que ce soit le foie les intestins
ra les poumons
mais c'est jamais nous c'est jamais
facile pour un peur de réussir dans la
langue de son fils
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux